rihanna 33 years old
a billionaire you may not know this
about rihanna
but she's got an incredible story and
one of the things we're going to do on
this show over and over and over again
is we're going to celebrate people
who are excellent you may know rihanna
for
music but she made majority of her
wealth outside of music
rihanna's story is one of those stories
that when you hear it you just want to
cheer for them you just want to
see them be successful she was born in
barbados
in a family where her father was an
alcoholic and i believe a crack cocaine
addict there was a domestic violence
situation in the home and she literally
as a young kid
would go with her father and sell
clothes as a street vendor
in the streets of barbados it doesn't
get
much harder than the life that rihanna
was born into
and lived in the early days of her life
today at the age of 33
literally 20 years later she's a
billionaire
this is what the opportunities
that exist in this world if you
understand
business if you understand finance if
you understand investing she's done a
fantastic job of taking the cars that
she was dealt
and navigating her way to becoming a
billionaire and so
the music that she has become famous for
obviously allowed her to build a massive
social audience
a massive fan base and to really build
the brand of rihanna but almost all of
the wealth has come from building
businesses
she became a billionaire not through
music
but by being a business owner by being
an entrepreneur and so
fenty beauty which was launched in 2017
four years ago is now worth estimated
2.8 billion dollars
she owns 50 of that 1.4 billion dollars
in net worth just from fenty
beauty she then has i believe this is a
lingerie company savage and fenty which
is worth an estimated 270 million
dollars
she owns 30 of that business
and so i'm sorry the company is worth a
billion dollars her
stake is worth 270 billion about 27 30
almost 30
and then the rest of her net worth comes
from music acting and entertainment
so we're looking at an individual who
came from the streets of barbados
literally selling
clothes as a street vendor in barbados
from a
home that no child should grow up in and
has been able to
build generational wealth this is what
entrepreneurship is all about
right to build not who cares about the
actual money itself
but to build financial security and
freedom for her her family her loved
ones
her children her grandchildren etc
this is what it is all about and so when
you start to look at this
she didn't leave barbados behind in 2018
she was
appointed as an ambassador of education
tourism and investment
by the government of barbados and so
forbes estimates her net
net worth at 1.7 billion dollars it
makes her the wealthiest
female musician in the world and she's
the second richest female
entertainer only behind oprah winfrey
she sold over 250 million records she's
earned 14
number one and 31 top 10 singles in the
us she's got nine grammys
12 billboard music awards six uh
guinness world records
she's got social media following of over
100 million followers
on both instagram and twitter
i hear these stories and i just get
excited
when somebody can go from basically
nothing and build
this type of insane value
and capture some of it for themselves
and their family right yeah well i think
what she did that was incredible was
uh you see a bunch of people that have
these large followings who
i forget what you said i think was 200
million she has across instagram and
twitter following why she's obviously a
massive presence
uh i didn't know she was only 33 years
old that surprised me a little bit but
she went and the company's only four
years old at this point and she said hey
look i have this massive audience
they'll buy essentially everything i put
out i can
keep doing these uh these endorsement
deals and these things that kind of all
these other companies want me to do and
maybe i'll get a small equity percentage
or whatever
but she said uh some some people will
say hey look i'll start it with a friend
i'll own
80 of it or whatever it is but she went
with lvmh and was like hey i'm going to
the top of the business i'm going to own
50
we're going to do it together we're
going to see how big we can make this
and four years later it's a billion
dollar company
multi-billion dollar company essentially
is this the new model
for entrepreneurs is to go build a
massive audience and then turn around
and build the businesses like go find
the customers and then just continuously
launch company after company because not
just one company she's launched yeah she
now has
two billion dollar companies that she is
a
founder partner whatever in right she's
got the fenty beauty which is the 2.8
billion dollar
uh cosmetic business and her makeup or
whatever it is categorized
and then two is savage and fenty which
is a billion-dollar business that she
owns 27 30
of yeah well it makes sense for both of
them right because she says hey look i
have this audience uh that i can
monetize
in whatever way i choose to necessarily
but they'll buy whatever i want
but i don't have any of kind of the
infrastructure or the background or
knowledge of the situation or this space
uh you guys are much more equipped lvmh
i'm talking about to go and do that
right you you have all the
infrastructure you have all this
the e-commerce everything uh kind of
around the world set up already so let's
partner on this together and then for
you guys it's going to make you much
more culturally relevant it's obviously
going to make you a lot of money
but it's also going to kind of amplify
everything else you guys are doing on
the other brands that you already own
so it makes a lot of sense for both
parties and look it's hard to argue with
the success it's a multi-billion dollar
company in in four years that
was literally uh was literally just
started like that so it's kind of
uh it's hard to argue she's not the only
one that's done it there's been a bunch
of people in the liquor space and all
these other kind of celebrities uh to do
similar models
but it's clearly working if you have
that that audience and that distribution
well as a brand you go and find
someone that has a distribution and
organically right so we were talking
about that
brother sister combo that started
selling candy out of texas what do they
do to really launch their brand very
well is they went to someone who was
from their hometown
who had a large following and said hey
if you like it can you post it
it's basically free for them right um
and it just gives you large distribution
right away is it possible to create a
luxury brand from scratch today without
having a
somebody with huge distribution like
will the next louis vuitton
uh or whatever be created without a
partnership like we've seen kanye do
this
they yeezy now uh his net worth is 6.6
billion dollars
uh they estimate um rihanna to be 1.7
billion
uh or so like is it now up at the point
where
all of the luxury brands or aspirational
brands that get built are going to be
from people who have large audiences
yeah well i think it's tough right
because they go hand in hand so like uh
virgil abloh is a good example with off
white like he became a celebrity
necessarily
as off-white became more popular and he
started doing all these other
partnerships
so when you get to a certain level i
think it goes hand in hand uh but like
in her case it's all about leverage i
think right like how can i
instead of selling uh you know whatever
it is she does sponsored posts or like
i think the thing with kim kardashian's
famous because she does like one million
dollars or more per post right so she'll
do a
sponsored instagram post get paid a
million dollars but then eventually
she's like all right why don't i just go
start my own company skims
and get some leverage and build a
business and get equity in it and then
eventually i can sell it for kind of
whatever i want essentially
uh so i think that that's kind of the
game of like how can i get more leverage
in this instead of
uh just going to sell and partner with
these people and get paid cash up front
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it